Frédéric Beigbeder vous venez de sortir
mémoire d'un jeune homme dérangé vous
vous sortez alors est-ce que vous amusez
à Paris est-ce que je crois qu'il faut
pas sortir si c'est pour se faire chier
quoi donc l'idée c'est quand même que le
seul moyen de s'amuser c'est
effectivement d'avoir un état d'esprit
fait à c'est pour ça que j'aime pas
l'expression chroniqueur mondain ce que
ça fait un peu parasite qui veut se
rehausser au niveau des stars alors que
bon j'aime bien soit les endroits hyper
comment dire copain du genre Castel
c'est hyper copain
non mais je veux dire les meilleurs
potes de Castel c'est pas la duchesse de
machin truc c'est voilà ce qui c'est au
port c'est bon c'est quand même pas tout
le monde ouais mais enfin c'est des
décodeurs
à part ça je crois que il faut vraiment
un esprit contradiction c'est à dire
qu'il faut aller dans un endroit branché
il faut être super chic et dans un
endroit super chic il faut être plutôt
crade voilà ça c'est l'esprit de
contradiction c'est important